il en faut pour tous les goûts en amour
c'est pourquoi il existe les objectifs
il ces personnes qui ont une attirance
sexuelle pour des objets improbables
comme les voitures
les anciens présentateurs de vidéo gag
ou encore les avions comme c'est le cas
de certaines personnes tout aussi
atypique j'espère me marier avec mon
boeing 737 et celle qui fait l'actu
c'est ça en rouleaux une allemande de 23
ans qu'elle a développé une attirance
plus précisément pour les maquettes
d'avions et surtout son boeing 737 pour
qu'elle parle ainsi j'ai remarqué que je
n'étais pas attiré par les personnes
parce que je n'avais pas envie de les
canines et contrairement à mes objets
c'est le meilleur sexe que je n'ai
jamais eu enfin bon temps qu'il ya de
l'amour
[Musique]
pardon la section rhône il est quand
même un peu court
voilà bien qui sont attirés par la tour
eiffel est quelqu'un qui s'était marié
avec la tour eiffel je rate
globalement des formes phalliques
souvent bien sûr
coréen qui s'est mariée avec son coussin
banga avec un
pas très sympa je préfère encore guillon
non je dis je préfère encore guillaume
vraiment vous allez tout antoine sept
mois
alors là
est ce qu'on entend et pour poser des
questions cette place-là les terrils
alors je vais rattraper des conneries
que j'avais des doutes mtl ou en ce
moment ça se passe pas mal on lire ça
m'est pas arrivé souvent non c'est vrai
à la tête de série madame je suis 3d
pendant les lâchers pas ça marche là
c'est beau ça j'en dis pas plus c'est
bien non c'est très bien ces remarques
ont pu se rattraper la connerie tanino
rotring car il est vrai aussi mais
c'était pas pareil mais c'est compliqué
à gérer mais la faute sur un secteur
j'avais une info surtout enfin là bas je
travaille à un débat sur les sextoys oui
non mais c'est que à l'époque il s'était
fait d'un matériau un peu dur
désagréable et tout ça donc c'était
vraiment bâtir pour daniel
c'était des siècles
c'était beau
c'était derrière elle avait dit midi et
aujourd'hui sont faits dans des
matériaux tellement d'ailleurs ça coûte
très cher à ses 500 600 euros jusqu'à
milan c'est ça aussi aujourd'hui ça
coûte nc ils sont faits dans des
matériaux tellement tellement brillant
est tellement proche que des gens qui
prennent plus de plaisir avec et sexton
est question a déçu maintenant lors de
la sexualité n'arrive pas à retrouver
les mêmes plaisirs je peux manger genre
de problème en ces beaux nouveau bon ça
fait longtemps qu'on aurait des machines
qui est sûre plus que nous ah oui
maintenant quand même reconnaît fait
figurer la même
non quand même pas non j'imagine aux
gens c'est un ami
un ami du caca les sextoys et qu'il me
dise à
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mykonos du 10 ans
[Rires]